non-minimalists
how do you balance setting boundaries
with a child
and allowing them room to explore and
learn
about who they are you know i think this
is fascinating damon because
the this is the the obviously
we've needed boundaries for millennia
right even pre-agriculture we were
living in caves
there were boundaries so we didn't get
eaten by a apex predator right
so even then parents needed bound
to set up boundaries i think the
difference now is quite often
we set up these sort of arbitrary
boundaries that are
in a way harmful to our children is that
fair
yeah we send mixed messages and we we
don't let them explore
i mean when you're starting with
boundaries you start with safety right
you can't touch the hot stove
you know the one or two-year-old you
can't touch the hot stove you can't
touch the electrical outlets
you're gonna hold my hand when we're
near the street those kind of boundaries
but you can let them explore and let
them ramble i always say
never lift a child into a tree but if
they can climb it they can climb as high
as they want because they can get down
if they can climb it and and so you have
your boundaries
um but but also let them operate within
their strengths abilities and
own personal limitations yeah yeah but
there was something pithy for you sean
to put in the show it's about the tree
climbing
that's solid yeah that's great i got
something uh pithy for you here our
desire to control impedes our ability to
love so i think quite often
i feel as though i want to control ella
right and because it's a there's a
certain righteousness in me when i do it
as well
and if i'm completely honest
there is a wow
there's a disdain for her behavior
and and that the stain is is really a
mirror reflecting
my own disdain for parenting lack of
parenting my own flaws etc
so i think whenever i whenever i try to
control
someone especially my child it
it often impedes my ability to to love
them to be
loving and
i think sometimes we confuse things that
feel loving
with the act of loving it might feel
loving in that moment to styrofoam or to
bubble wrap everything to keep her safe
but that's not an act of love
that's act of fear i'm gonna take the
next 90 minutes
to answer that question because there
are so many levels there
the the first level is um it has to do
with your expectations
yes i expect a certain outcome and if it
doesn't go that way
then i'm disappointed that's your own
personal issues your own baggage you got
to deal with that
um but you have to make sure your
expectations are realistic so
if you have a five-year-old and you're
wondering how i can get them to want to
clean their room
that's not realistic five-year-olds
don't want to clean their room they
might
learn how to clean their room or they
might learn that they have to clean
their room but they're not going to want
to and if that's your expectation
you're going to constantly be
disappointed in your child which is
really disappointed in your own
expectation
the second thing to know is you know we
talked about boundaries
and um if you ever rode a roller coaster
and i'm sure you have
uh the first thing you do when you get
into a roller coaster is you pull that
safety bar down oh yeah
and the next thing you do everybody
shakes it right you shake it because you
want to make sure it's going to be there
when you need it
right that's what your kids are going to
do they're going to shake you you're
going to put your rule
and they're going to shake you and you
can't take that personally that's what
they're supposed to do
they're supposed to test whether or not
it's a real
thing that's going on here so so that's
that's really important to know that
they're going to test you
and i guess the third point to emphasize
is
you know sting says if you love someone
you've got to let them go right
as your kids get older you have to give
them more freedom to be who they are
they have to find their friends and
figure out what their passions and
interests are and it may not be yours
and so i talk to teens all the time and
i say to them
you've got to help your parents let go
you have to let them know
that you're safe by letting them know
that you'll be a home at a certain time
and then come home at a certain time
that's how you're preparing them for you
going off to college and becoming an
adult
because parenting is traumatizing
parenting is is absolutely traumatized i
mean we're in the middle of the night
we're we're up at two in the morning
holding our child who
who's diarrheaed all over us and and and
throwing up on us and doing all this
it's traumatizing so
by the time you have a teenager we all
have parenting ptsd a little bit
yeah and and the way you deal with
somebody with ptsd
is you give them assurances and not just
tell them but you show them
over and over it's gonna be okay and
that's what i need teens to learn to do
to their parents
is to show us that it's going to be okay
so when it's time to let go
we as parents are able to do that it's a
two-way street
it's really great advice for parents
with with teenagers because
you know it seems like the parents are
always setting the boundaries
but asking the teenagers to do that um
it's not a huge ask and uh yeah it
creates a
great relationship with their parents
that's great advice um
my pithy answer is this we often don't
discover our boundaries
until they've been crossed so what i
mean by that
is there are the obvious boundaries that
parents can set don't touch the hot
stove hold my hand as we're crossing the
street look both ways wear your seatbelt
there are these obvious boundaries
but then there are some boundaries that
aren't so obvious like you know when is
the appropriate curfew
um when is the appropriate date age to
start dating
i mean there there are these things that
i feel like
and again not having kids it's so easy
to give parenting advice so
you tell me damon how if i'm way off
base here but i feel like as a parent
you have to be willing to let your kids
fail a little bit so what i mean by that
is
i grew up like my dad was a very strict
christian father so i had these
boundaries that i was constantly
crossing that he had set because they
were a little bit too extreme
my mom was on the other side where she
gave me no boundaries so i had to kind
of discover you know what my boundaries
were with her
um but yeah what do you think about that
as far as like how
what can we tell parents to help them
maybe be okay with like
letting their kids fail a little bit and
discovering those boundaries
on their own so you know there is no
perfect parenting book because every
child is different you mean your book
isn't the perfect parenting book it's
really close
in fact what i try to do is i i try to
talk
in terms of concepts parenting concepts
these are the big picture things because
to apply it to individual children if i
say this is the best way to do this
it really depends on your child on their
temperament and their experiences
because you're right every boundary can
be crossed in a different way and you
can't predict and anticipate
every single way right so so yeah it
really depends on
on the way your child's going to turn
and then you fall back on the basics
you know what's the big picture here why
am i upset
and fall back on that because if you can
model big picture thinking when you're
dealing with
that's it i'm taking away your phone for
the next three weeks well
you know just because they swore at me
is that really worth taking away their
phone or through
maybe they swarmed me because they're
really mad at me and maybe there's a
reason for them to be mad you know you
have to step back and see the big
picture
um but yeah they'll cross boundaries you
never even knew existed